eu sou professora de direito
internacional
o curso de relações internacionais
e nesse ano com base numa formação em
educação positiva eu resolvi com e pedir
pra conhecer os estudantes e me
apresentar pedindo pra eles
compartilharem suas experiências
positivas que eles tiveram na
universidade nesse último ano e
reiteradamente esses estudantes
expressavam o quanto o ambiente diverso
na academia a diversidade no ambiente
acadêmico tinha promovido o
desenvolvimento pessoal
a ampliação de horizontes esses
estudantes são estudantes da
universidade federal da integração
latino-americana a unila e é importante
a gente tentar compreender e perceber
porque une lá as políticas públicas de
educação são complexas com dificuldade
de aprofundamento na opinião pública e
sobretudo uma universidade com uma
vocação internacional como esta temática
a idéia da integração latino americana
então eu vou buscar fundamental aqui e
as cinco razões porque unila
a primeira razão diz respeito à
necessidade de conectar a qualidade da
educação com a internacionalização
grande parte dos rankings do ensino
superior que tentam medir a qualidade
das instituições atribuem um percentual
significativo em regra 25% dos
indicadores a internacionalização
rankings como a folha de são paulo mas
também os internacionais como que esta
higher education e talvez a gente possa
fazer uma analogia com os corredores de
biodiversidade dos parques das florestas
né
os corredores de biodiversidade permitem
um fluxo de diversidade de fauna e flora
a partir das florestas mantendo a sua
riqueza ea sua existência sua vida assim
como na produção do conhecimento isso é
fundamental
esses corredores de diversidade de
formas de saber e de formas de produzir
conhecimento
o segundo aspecto importante que
fundamenta a existência ea razão dessa
ideia é a questão de projetar para o
futuro porque a tendência nossa no
projeto civilizatório é de integração de
estados e povos e isso nós conseguimos
observar pelo conjunto de fatos que se
apresenta com base no processo de
integração regional a gente observa aí o
aprofundamento da união européia
mercosul vários blocos de econômicos
regionais
se nós observamos apenas o caso da
organização mundial do comércio
raríssimos os estados que não estão
negociando com base no bloco econômico
regional
então o presente eo futuro do processo
civilizatório é de integração de estados
e povos e é preciso formar neste sentido
a unila por exemplo o ano de 2019
atingiu a marca de 32 nacionalidades nos
seus bancos acadêmicos
agora esse processo de integração ele se
constitui com base também na
solidariedade uma solidariedade que não
oferece essas oportunidades e essas
vagas
mas isso está bastante conectado também
ao interesse nacional e essa é a
terceira razão para o do porque une lá
nós temos fortes razões diz fundamental
que a uni la é um projeto que atende se
fundamenta também no interesse nacional
à política externa dos países se
constrói bastante com o soft power o
poder de influência que é baseado nas
relações interpessoais e nos vínculos
eu mesmo fui bolsista de um programa no
canadá que se chama líderes emergentes
das américas é e assim como tem por
exemplo é um programa no reino unido se
chama the british council e numa
oportunidade a gente tinha aqui na
cidade
um pessoal da embaixada do reino unido e
eles oportunizaram e na sala de aula
divulgar um programa de estudos no reino
unido
e conversando com os estudantes
apresentaram o programa e os estudantes
de relações internacionais muito
curiosos
perguntaram por que que o reino unido
oferecia vagas gratuitamente da bolsas
para estudantes estrangeiros irem para o
seu país estudar ea razão foi muito
claro
ela respondeu na hora soft power
eles constroem vínculos esses estudantes
sim eles estudantes têm uma relação
privilegiada com o nosso país e eles vão
ser futuros líderes dos seus países o
brasil mesmo tem um programa que chama
programa de estudante-convênio que
existe há mais de 50 anos
hoje boa parte dos governantes de angola
por exemplo estudaram no brasil
então essas relações estes vínculos eles
pavimentam uma relação com o brasil que
é de outro nível
né que é de outra condição de relações e
de aprofundamento de vínculos é ele se
torna um pouco também brasileiro é esse
é isso que se constroem um senso de
pertencimento que constrói condições e
dá oportunidades para construir a
integração a quarta razão é que a une lá
é a cara de foz do iguaçu é a questão
territorial
a unila está sediada numa fronteira
trinacional é a fronteira mais viva da
américa latina onde nós temos mais de 80
etnias convivendo cotidianamente
fronteira com o paraguai fronteira com a
argentina mas também um espaço de
diversidade não só cultural mas também
de diversidade é de biodiversidade né
além do parque nacional e das da grande
maravilha que são que a natureza das
cataratas nós temos também uma grande
obra de engenharia monumental que a
itaipu binacional também obra de
engenharia política internacional
o espaço uma empresa binacional que
fornece quase 20 por cento de toda a
energia para o brasil e 90% da energia
do paraguai e que se constrói no
encontro de dois países
então está em foz do iguaçu faz todo
sentido fomenta tanto a qualidade eo a
necessidade de conhecimento do
território quanto da universidade é
incrível
nós temos uma internacionalização de
curta distância quase 200 estudantes da
unila que vem à foz do iguaçu estudar
todos os dias eles saem de outro país
eles saem das suas cidades onde dormem
no paraguai ou na argentina e vem
estudar aqui
essa riqueza só poderia acontecer em foz
do iguaçu a quinta razão ela diz
respeito a uma razão de tecnológica que
disse que a questão da geopolítica do
conhecimento
vejo o pensamento filosófico da
modernidade se desenvolveu em grande
medida com base numa dada geografia num
determinado horizonte de sentidos que
tem uma localidade que tem um ponto de
referência e ele não leva tanto em
consideração as nossas realidades né e a
unila se constrói na perspectiva da
relação sul-sul é entendendo que há uma
geopolítica do conhecimento que precisa
ser contemplada na produção de saberes e
é por isso que nós nos focamos bastante
nessa questão de incluir também povos
originários
nós trabalhamos por exemplo né a unila
universidade bilíngue
nós temos um português e um espanhol mas
também temos o guarani
temos o cacho e temos muitos outros
idiomas que tentam incorporar uma
ecologia de saberes
a grande questão é que é preciso
entender que as universidades são bem
público estratégico e social esse é um
consenso entre os especialistas da
educação a universidade como bem público
social e estratégico ea uni la na medida
em que ela passa a incluir uma grande
diversidade de estudantes não só do
ponto de vista das questões de
nacionalidades de povos
tinhas mas também de idiomas de formas
de saber povos originários a inclusão
dos povos originários que é um gargalo
no nosso processo civilizatório na
américa latina e isso permite com que a
gente responda tanto o processo de
internacionalização que é um indicador
de qualidade quanto à formação de
cidadãos que vão estar preparados para a
construção da sociedade do presente e
futuro defendendo e fundamentando que o
interesse nacional também se constrói
com solidariedade e com na construção de
relações internacionais fomentando um
espaço importante do território de foz
do iguaçu
vejo o foz do iguaçu recebe o ensino
superior
apenas em 1979 a universidade já
completa 800 anos
na américa latina as universidades
chegou no século 16 em foz do iguaçu em
a unila começa apenas em 2010 então esse
é um projeto que o presente e futuro que
vai transformar também o território a
partir de uma outra ecologia de saberes
e é por isso que a unila universidade
federal da integração latino-americana é
assim um bem público social e
estratégico para a sociedade
latino-americana para a sociedade
brasileira e para foz do iguaçu
obrigado
[Aplausos]